♪ ♪
>> Mike: WELCOME BACK TO THIS
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY."
AS STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ATTEMPT TO MITIGATE THE SPREAD
OF COVID-19, SOMEONE NOW BEING
ACCUSED OF TRAMPLING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN HOUSTON A NEW
MANDATE WOULD FIND RESIDENCE
$1,000 FOR JUST NOT WEARING A
MASK IN PUBLIC.
HOUSTON’S POLICE UNION PRESIDENT
IS CALLING THE MEASURE
DRACONIAN.
OTHERS ARE PROTESTING THE
MANDATE, WHICH IS NOW FACING A
COURT CHALLENGE.
IN MICHIGAN, STATE LAWMAKERS ARE
ATTEMPTING TO STRAIN THE
GOVERNMENT EMERGENCY POWERS
AFTER SHE ISSUED WIDESPREAD
BANDS, AT ONE POINT EVEN
PROHIBITING MEMBERS OF THE SAME
FAMILY FROM VISITING EACH OTHER.
MY GUESS IS THERE ARE SOME
FAMILIES WHO WOULD ACTUALLY
APPROVE OF THAT, BUT NOT MANY.
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHITMER
ANNOUNCED TODAY THAT SHE IS
GOING TO EASE SOME OF THE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS BY THE
GOVERNOR CONTINUES TO FACE A
WAVE OF CRITICISM.
AND IN WASHINGTON STATE, THAT
STAYED ONE VOTE AWAY FROM
RELEASING SOME OF ITS MOST
DANGEROUS INMATES.
ALL TO FIGHT THE SPREAD OF
COVID-19.
AND A 5-4 DECISION, THE STATE
SUPREME COURT DENIES THE RELEASE
OF THESE CONVICTS, INCLUDING
POTENTIALLY THE GREEN RIVER
KILLER.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR TREY GOWDY.
YOU WERE IN CONGRESS LONG ENOUGH
TO NOT LIKE IT VERY WELL.
YOU ARE BACK HOME IN
SOUTH CAROLINA, BUT WHAT WE ARE
SEEN ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY IS
SOME VERY HEAVY HANDED POLICIES
BEING PASSED OUT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL BY GOVERNORS AND MAYORS.
IS THIS A THREAT TO THE
LONG-TERM LIFE AND LIBERTY OF
THE UNITED STATES AND ITS
PEOPLE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, GOVERNOR, IT’S
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
THERE HAS TO BE IRRATIONALITY.
ANY TIME GOVERNOR ASKS THE
CITIZENRY TO DO SOMETHING THERE
HAS TO BE A RATIONAL BASIS FOR
IT IN THE GREATER THE FREEDOM
YOU INFRINGE, THE MORE
COMPELLING THE REASON HAS TO BE.
IF I’M GOING TO IMPRISON YOU OR
FINE YOU FOR NOT WEARING A MASK,
WHY CAN I HOLD YOU DOWN AND
VACCINATE YOU AGAINST THE FLU
THIS FALL?
YOU DON’T WANT THE FLU AND
COVID-19, SO CAN I INVOLUNTARILY
VACCINATE YOU CUSTOMER CAN I
SHOW UP AT YOUR HOUSE AND MAKE
SURE YOU ARE DOING YOUR BURPEE’S
AND YOUR JUMPING JACKS BECAUSE O
OBESITY AND COVID-19 DON’T GO WE
TOGETHER.
WHERE DOES IT STOP?
AND IN HOUSTON, GOVERNOR, IF YOU
CAN BELIEVE THIS, THEY ARE
THREATENING TO PUNISH PEOPLE FOR
NOT WEARING A MASK.
MEANWHILE ON WASHINGTON STATE
THEY ARE GOING TO LET A SERIAL
KILLER, THEY ARE 1 FOOT AWAY
FROM LETTING A SERIAL KILLER OUT
BECAUSE OF OF COVID-19.
GO TO JAIL FOR NOT WEARING A
MASK BUT IF YOU KILL FOR A DOZEN
WOMEN BECAUSE OF COVID-19 WE
MIGHT LET YOU OUT.
THAT IS A RATIONAL.
>> Mike: YOU ARE A PROSECUTOR
PRIOR TO GOING TO CONGRESS HE
UNDERSTAND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THE POWER OF
THE GOVERNMENT AND WHAT THEY CAN
DO.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN ALSO
DEFEND CIVIL LIBERTIES RIGHT NOW
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR
INDICATES HE IS WILLING TO STAND
UP FOR CITIZENS TO MAKE SURE
THAT CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS DON’T
GET TRAMPLED ON.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THAT?
>> WE ARE LUCKY.
WE HAVE A REAL LAWYER AS THE AG.
I MEAN, HE IS A REAL LAWYER.
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT FOR
GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO IMPINGE
ON A FREEDOM THAT HAS TO BE A
RATIONAL BASIS AND SOMETIMES A
COMPELLING REASON.
SO, IF I’M GOING TO TELL YOU,
GOVERNOR, THAT YOU CAN’T VISIT
YOUR MOM, THAT IS A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT THAT YOU HAVE.
SO THE REASON I OFFERED TO KEEP
YOU FROM DOING THAT HAS TO BE
INCREDIBLY COMPELLING.
IT HAS TO BE MORE THAN JUST THE
GOVERNOR OF MICHIGAN THINKS IT’S
A GOOD IDEA.
IF I TELL YOU THAT YOU HAVE TO
WEAR SOMETHING IN PUBLIC, THERE
HAS TO BE A RATIONAL BASIS FOR
THAT.
BILL BARR IS SMART ENOUGH TO
KNOW THAT HE WILL PUT THE POWER
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
GRANTS IN THOSE STATES AND
MUNICIPALITIES WHO DON’T WANT TO
GO ALONG, THE POWER TO GO TO
COURT.
>> Mike: CONGRESSMAN GAUDI,
WE’VE SEEN SOME PRETTY CRAZY
STUFF.
MICHIGAN THE GOVERNOR SAYS YOU
CAN’T MOW YOUR LAWN.
I HAVE A HARD TIME UNDERSTANDING
HOW MOWING MY LAWN IS GOING TO
MAKE ME MORE SUBJECT TO GETTING
THE COVID-19 VIRUS.
>> IT IS THE RESPONSE -- YOU ARE
THE GOVERNOR OF THE GREAT STATE,
ARKANSAS.
SHE’S THE GOVERNOR OF A GREAT
STATE.
DOES HER JOB JOB TO PERSUADE HER
CITIZENRY THAT WHAT SHE’S
TELLING THEM YOU CANNOT DO IS
RATIONALLY ROOTED IN PUBLIC
HEALTH.
GOOD LUCK CONVINCING ANYONE THAT
MOWING YOUR FRONT LAWN IS GOING
TO MAKE YOU MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
COVID-19.
LOOK, I GET ENCOURAGING PEOPLE
NOT TO SEE THOSE WHO ARE
VULNERABLE.
BUT ASKING ME TO NOT SEE MY MOM
IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM TELLING
ME THAT I AM FORBIDDEN ON
PENALTY OF LAW FROM GOING TO SEE
MY MOM AND THAT IS WHAT THE
PROTESTERS AND OTHERS -- I’M NOT
A PROTESTER BUT I WANT
GOVERNMENT TO EXPLAIN TO ME, IF
I’M GOING TO INFRINGE ON YOUR
FREEDOM FOR A COMPELLING REASON,
AMERICANS ARE SACRIFICIAL.
YOU KNOW THAT.
THEY ARE SACRIFICIAL.
BUT IT’S NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK,
WHY ARE YOU MAKING ME DO THAT?
AND IS IT ROOTED IN SOME
RATIONALITY IN WHAT WE ARE
TRYING TO PREVENT QWEST MARKET
AND IF IT’S NOT THAT WE
HAVE THIS THING CALLED CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE THAT PEOPLE CAN
ENGAGE IN.
>> Mike: AND I THINK THAT IS
WHAT WE ARE SEEING.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE READY TO
ENGAGE IN IT.
THEY ARE NOT UNREASONABLE AND I
APPRECIATE YOU SAYING THAT
BECAUSE THE PROTESTERS AREN’T
ALL JUST A BUNCH OF CRAZIES.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
FUNDAMENTALLY KNOW WHAT THEIR
BASIC RIGHTS ARE.